coming up on 6 26 on your friday morning  what's cool at school well we are  following up on that elementary school  fundraiser we told you about where they  weren't selling anything  hayes elementary pta vice president beth  newett tells us they got about 9 400 in  donations that turned into nearly 700  acts of kindness on their kindness tree  that included a food drive for project  150  friendship bracelets greeting cards  chalk on the walk messages and a  school-wide foam party to celebrate  so with all the money raised the pta at  hayes planning to buy hydration stations  for the school and next year they want  to raise enough money to build an  outdoor classroom for their garden now  if you know something that's cool at  school let us know head to 8newsnow.com  look for the community tab then click  cool at school or you can send us me  send us an email cool at school at  8newsnow.com